Hey everyone! So far we have taken care of ...
production and cost. We saw how those two things ...
related to one another. We have looked at ...
accounting profits and economic profit.
Now we're going to take a look at these average costs ...
and how the marginal-average relationship ...
works. Let's go ahead and jump into.
Here we have the table that we were working with.
We have our total product, fixed cost,
variable cost, total cost and are marginal ...
cost. We got all of our explanation ...
as to why these different types of costs take on the ...
roles that they take on. Now let's take a look at what ...
we call average fixed cost. Average fixed cost is going to ...
be fixed costs divided by the amount of output we have.
So at a fixed cost of $1,000, and it stays the same ...
throughout entire range of output that we have,
all we simply do is take that $1,000 and divide by our total ...
product. And you see that this is going ...
to give us our different values for fixed cost or average fixed ...
cost. Now notice what happens ...
with average fixed cost. It is always falling and that is ...
because the numerator, in this case $1,000,
stays the same as output continues to increase.
So this is going to start us off very high on our graph and ...
it's going to continue to fall until it gets closer and closer ...
to the horizontal axis. Now let's look at our next ...
type of average cost and that's average variable cost,
will call this AVC. And like average fixed cost,
average variable cost is going to be the variable cost divided ...
by our output. So we can see here
with an average variable cost of 400 what we did was we ...
took the $800 and we divided it by the two of our content ...
that you created. So this gives us 800 /
2 which is $400. And we do this through the ...
entire range of variable cost and total product.
Now, a difference with average ...
variable cost compared to average fixed cost is that its ...
first decreases and then it increases.
And again this is because of diminishing marginal returns.
Diminishing marginal returns sets in and our costs begin to ...
rise as we begin to use more and more workers on the ...
fixed amount of resources that we have--the fixed ...
amount of capital and this causes our costs.
This goes into our variable cost and we will see that ...
diminishing marginal returns come into play.
The last type of cost that we have is average total cost or ...
ATC. This is our total cost divided ...
by our quantity or we can say it is our average fixed cost ...
plus our average variable cost.
So all we have to do is simply add our average fixed cost ...
and our average variable cost together and what you will ...
see is that we are going to get our average total cost by doing so.
And again because
Average total cost has average variable cost built ...
into it we are going to again experience diminishing ...
marginal returns. You'll notice that we have ...
increasing returns up to our 12 units being produced--12 ...
types of content being created and then it begins to ...
increase. So at first we decrease and ...
then we increase. What does all this mean?
What is all this look like? Let's have a look.
Here we have our different cost curves.
We have this purple line representing our marginal ...
cost. The green line is our average ...
fixed cost, and notice what happens.
We start up here and we approach the horizontal axis ...
as we continue to increase more and more output.
Now look at our average variable cost--this blue line.
Iit first decreases and then it begins to increase and again ...
this is because of diminishing marginal returns.
And our red line--that is the average total cost--it does the ...
same thing it first falls
and then it begins to rise. Okay.
So what we are seeing again is diminishing marginal ...
returns kick in. At initially 0,
2 and 5 units of created content what we are seeing is ...
that when we add a few workers to amount to all the ...
idle resources that we have they can begin to really ...
increase production and our costs are going to fall.
But because we only have a set amount of fixed resources ...
when I get to the 12th or 14th and 15th content created ...
what's going to happen? Despite all those extra ...
workers that are hired they are all working on the same ...
amount of fixed resources which then means it's more ...
costly to me and I'm not getting as much out of it.
We see this as well with the marginal cost curve.
You'll notice what takes place is that the marginal cost ...
curve begins to fall for a little bit and then it rises and that ...
again because as we start to produce the additional unit of ...
output initially what takes place is our marginal cost will ...
fall, but again because I'm adding ...
more and more workers to a fixed amount of resources ...
that are available to them any additional unit of output that I ...
create or that you create is going to raise the cost of ...
those additional units of output.
Now let's take a look at the shapes of these curves.
We already know that diminishing marginal returns ...
gives us the shapes of these curves,
but what we also see is that they have thus U shape.
They fall and then they rise. And then we see that there ...
are two points here where the marginal cost curve is going ...
to intersect the average variable cost and the average ...
total curve. This is what we would call ...
minimum efficient scale. Okay.
Minimum efficient scale. And what that means is that ...
we have found the point where average variable and ...
average total cost are at their lowest and the marginal cost ...
curve intersects them at their lowest.
This brings us to the marginal average relationship.
And this relationship simply says that the margin always ...
leads the average. Think about a baseball player ...
who has a batting average that sits at 0.500.
The next time that baseball player goes up to bat what ...
happens? That's the marginal at bat.
If they get a hit and they get on base then their batting ...
average increases. If they strike out or fly out any ...
other way that they don't generate a way to get on the ...
base what happens? Then their batting average ...
will fall. So the margin will pull up or ...
it will pull down the average. As I begin to hire more ...
workers they increase their output.
So the additional units of output that are being ...
generated lower the marginal cost and that pulls down ...
average cost. But at some point what is ...
going to happen? The additional units that I ...
continue to create from my additional workers are going ...
to cost me more, so my marginal cost ...
increases and that will then pull up the average.
Notice that the marginal cost curve will fall before or get to ...
its lowest points before the average cost curves do.
And then it begins to rise. And as it rises it's going to ...
pull these average cost curves up and if you didn't ...
notice the average total cost curve and the average ...
variable cost curve the distance between those two ...
is just the average fixed cost curve.
Okay! That is it for our cost curves.
Hope you enjoyed it, and we'll catch you in our last one.